when you see news about Africa it's
usually Ebola displacement or Boko Haram
right but there's another side to the
continent that doesn't get reported its
innovative the government is invested
heavily in e-commerce
environmentally-conscious we're talking
about 15,000 600 fishermen in Nigeria
who demanded that shell clean up the
huge mess it made full of young
passionate people today half of its
population is under 20 growing economies
in 2014 foreign investments were
predicted to reach a record high of 80
billion dollars starting in February aj+
will focus on Africa and talk to
Millennials who are making a difference
there once those stories that fix
problems plus we look at how the
upcoming Nigerian elections will have
implications for the rest of the world
it now has the largest economy on the
continent
surpassing South Africa in 2013 we're
gonna help you hit the reset button on
Africa
you